[Music]
the development of the asphalt paver in
the early part of the 20th century
changed the way roads were built the
paving machine took over from large
crews who paved surfaces manually using
picks and shovels this invention has
made it a lot easier to pave the way the
asphalt paver transforms rough roads
into smooth ones this paving machine
distributes asphalt levels it and also
provides the initial compaction making
one starts with a computerized plasma
cutter the operator programs it to cut
out all the parts of the paper structure
from heavy gauge steel plates
it also configures the cutting to
minimize waste the plasma tooling also
cuts and threads holes for bolting the
parts together
once the parts have been cut a crane
transfers them to a welding fixture the
fixture holds the parts for the paver
frame in tight alignment while a welder
text them together
[Music]
he also tack welds smaller parts like
engine mounts to the structure once the
tack welds are done he does full wells
throughout creating strong thick seams a
[Music]
team loads more steel into a
computerized press break it clamps the
steel plate between a matching punch and
die then using hydraulic power the press
break makes precise bends to shape the
steel into a section of the paver hopper
with the first been done one of the
workers measures the angle with the
digital level to confirm that it's
exactly right the team then moves the
steel plate into position for the next
bends they make a total of three in the
hopper part those three bands must be
perfectly angled and positioned to fit
the rest of the hopper
[Music]
it's why precision is critical
they do a final check of the three bends
using the template next a welder joins a
side panel to the hopper part with the
three bends these two parts form the
left side of the hopper
[Music]
after an acid-wash it's into the paint
move to coat the steel with an epoxy
primer and urethane paint
[Music]
the parts then spend time in an oven to
accelerate the paint cure
then it's over to the assembly line
where construction of the paper tractor
is already underway
a worker bolts gear systems to the sides
these gears will drive the paver wheels
with the help of a crane the team guides
the engine into position
the engines mounting structure mates to
bushings in four locations they now
assemble the hopper to the front of the
paving machine hinge tubes on the hopper
part intermesh with tubes on the center
conveyor framework they'll run a long
pin through these hinge tubes to
complete the assembly with everything in
good working order they're ready to
build the screed beginning with the base
plate the screed is a critical apparatus
it's system of vibrating extenders both
levels and compacts the asphalt once
it's deposited on the road
they're also equipped with heating
elements to keep the asphalt workable
they run a battery of tests on all these
components to confirm that the screed is
fully operational
the screed is now ready to be mated to
the paver tractor they put the tractor
in reverse and back it up to the screed
until brackets on both meet in perfect
alignment
once the brackets have been bolted
together the asphalt paver is ready for
work the road ahead will be long and
potentially winding but it should be
pretty smooth
thanks to this asphalt paver